Banksy is very famous for stenciling on very anonymous walls around the world.
And I think this is part of that legacy...
...where he's taking various art historical motifs...
...and kind of inserting himself into that narrative.
Banksy's "Diamond in the Rough" is clearly a contemporary work of art...
...but it shares common elements from Egyptian art.
The vertical panel, the pictorial language and a figure of a girl...
...offering all share characteristics that we see in this ancient culture.
The panel itself has an oval window which is reminiscent of a cartouche...
...which is a pictorial plane that holds hieroglyphs...
...that tell about the Egyptian Pharaoh whose property it is.
There's depth and there's a complexity to it.
Banksy is clearly part of that lineage that Basquiat and Herring...
...kind of established in the early 80s of street art being turned into fine art.
The painting is called "Diamond in the Rough".
So, it's sort of beauty in unexpected places.